und jetzt das heute journal mit
kaiselverichter und Dunja
Hayali schönen guten Abend setzen die
USA seine Vetomacht ein oder nicht sie
haben es nicht getan aber auch nur weil
der Beschluss des Weltsicherheitsrats
deutlich entschärft wurde Verstöße gegen
das humanitäre Völkerrecht
einschließlich aller willkürlichen
Angriffe gegen Zivilisten und zivile
Objekte stehen in der verbindlichen
Resolution nicht mehr drin dafür aber
eine Aufstockung der humanitären Hilfe
im Gasastreifen und die ist dringend
notwendig denn um die humanitäre
Situation der Menschen dort zu
beschreiben gibt es eigentlich kaum noch
passende Worte von es wird immer
schlimmer über katastrophal sind wir
jetzt bei unerträglich angelangt eine
Versorgung in den wenigen noch
operierenden Krankenhäusern ist kaum
noch zu gewährleisten Medikamente sind
knapp Wasser auch Lebensmittel erst
recht über die Situation in Gaza Susanna
Santina es war ein funkenhoffnung den
viele Menschen Gase hatten als ein
zweiter Grenzübergang für Hilfe geöffnet
wurde auch Sultan abuada ist gekommen
aus Verzweiflung er und seine Familie
waren vor den israelischen Angriffen aus
gazastadt nach Raffa
geflogen wir leiden so einen Hunger wir
warten ständig darauf dass etwas von den
Lastwagen fällt wir wollen leben 10 000
Vertriebene Familien leiden hier für die
Menschen in Gaza wird die Lage immer
dramatischer der Vorsitzende des
Welternährungsprogramms schlägt Alarm
über 500.000 würden hier an akutem
Hunger leiten vom un Generalsekretär
kommt erneut die Forderung nach einer
humanitären
Waffenruhe die Art und Weise wie Israel
diese Angriffe führt verhindert massiv
die Verteilung humanitärer Hilfe in Gaza
die fortlaufenden israelischen
Bombardierungen nach dem Terrorangriff
der Hamas haben tausende getötet auch
viele
Kinder die Krankenhäuser die noch
funktionieren sind wegen der vielen
Verletzten am Limit im Norden Gazas
arbeitet nach UN-Angaben kein einziges
mehr da sich hamasterroristen in zivilen
Gebäuden verstecken sagt die israelische
Armee geb es leider auch viele zivile
Opfer auch in Israel leiden die Menschen
vor allem die Angehörigen der
mittlerweile über 470 getöteten
Soldaten und die der Geiseln die Mutter
einer der drei Geiseln die versehentlich
durch israelische Soldaten getötet
wurden rüt derzeit viele in Israel mit
ihren
Worten ich liebe euch Soldaten ihr sollt
wissen dass das was passiert ist nicht
eure Schuld
ist in Tel Aviv übernachten noch immer
viele Angehörige der Geiseln vor dem
Verteidigung isterium 129 sind noch in
der Gewalt der Terroristen die Chancen
für eine schnelle Freilassung stehen
schlecht bei all den schrecklichen
Bildern bei all den Toten im
gazerastreifen verblasst in der
Öffentlichkeit mehr und mehr der Anlass
für diesen Krieg es war das Massaker der
Terrorgruppe Hamas am 7 Oktober mit über
1200 Opfern und mindestens 240
verschleppten Geiseln und ja Fr
zur Verhältnismäßigkeit zur Taktik
Strategie und dem danach dürfen und
müssen gestellt werden und das werden
sie auch auf dem internationalen
politischen pket das sollte aber nicht
zu einer schuldumkehr führen geschweige
denn zu Antisemitismus aber genau das
passiert auch hier bei uns chr
lepple ein lichtsetzen in dunklen Zeiten
das hilft und guter
swing
der Musiker andre Hamlin ist auf den
Bühnen der Welt erfolgreich seit dem
Hamas Massaker vom 7 Oktober aber fühlt
sich der Berliner bandlieder verlassen
und
verzweifelt auf einmal hörte ich überall
ja aber und überall hörte ich Aufschreie
der Empörung die sich aber
merkwürdigerweise nicht gegen die chamas
und gegen die judenmörder richteten
sondern gegen Israel und gegen die Juden
die sie auch noch die deutschen Juden
die sie praktisch in ein Art von
sittenhaft Namen andre Hamlin ist ein
Berliner Jude der zweiten Generation
sein Vater der Schriftsteller Stefan
Hermlin überlebte den Holocaust nur dank
Flucht und Exil das sprät die Hermlin
bis heute überleben wenn wir schon S
weit sind dass ein Antisemitismus
Beauftragte der Bundesregierung Juden
empfehlt keine Kipper zu tragen dann
zeigt das das Problem das Gegenteil ist
der Fall er muss ihn empfehlen mit einer
Kipper zu gehen und er muss dafür sorgen
dass jene die sie bedrohen dass den auf
die Finger gehauen wirdai zwatzki
gleichfalls 58 Jahre und Nachkomme von
Holocaust Überlebenden die Kipper trägt
er nur noch für unsere Kamera oder in
der Synagoge auch für ihn hat sich alles
geändert wenn ich in der U-Bahn bin und
ich bekomme eine Telefonate von einem
israelischen Freund oder von meinem Sohn
und ich möchte gerne aufbr sprechen und
ich muss da rechts und links gucken ob
die Umgebung nicht feindlich ist
ja Angst herrscht mich in diesem Moment
ili geboren in Israel kam vor 24 Jahren
nach Deutschland seine Eltern überlebten
wie durch ein Wunder die nazierrschaft
in Polen sie bekam drei Kinder Eli der
jüngste zog 1999 nach Berlin sein Fazit
heute es gibt sogar viele Menschen die
es genießen
dass es den Juden schlecht geht und dass
Juden verfolgt werden und das Juden
wiederleiden und nicht nur im Nahen
Osten auch
hier müssen sich Juden in Deutschland
wieder unsichtbar machen und gibt es
eine Chance auf einen Frieden mit der
Hamas ich glaube dass
am Ende die Frage ist die oder wir das
hört niemand gern weil man ja immer gern
von Frieden und Verhandlung und
Gespräche
äh redet aber wissen Sie sie können
nicht mit Leuten verhandeln die die
erklärte Absicht haben sie auszurotten
ili zwatzki ist in dieser Frage
optimistischer und es ist möglich es ist
möglich in Frieden zu
leben heute war für alle Schüler und
Schülerinnen der letzte Schultag vor den
Ferien die meisten dürften sich jetzt
auf Weihnachten freuen einfach mal
abschalten wobei das mit dem Abschalten
stimmt ja so gar nicht mehr die meisten
sind ständig online verbunden über das
Smartphone festgeklebt an Ihrem Tablet
es wird gewischt und geliked gepostet
und gechattet Ruhephasen Mangelware das
könnte mit ein Grund dafür sein dass
immer mehr Schüler bereits in der
Grundschule
Konzentrationsschwierigkeiten haben und
wer sich nicht konzentrieren kann der
kann nichts aufnehmen und der kann dann
auch nichts lernen die Ergebnisse der
PIs Studie sind nur der Beweis dafür was
viele Lehrkräfte seit Jahren wissen aber
was hilft mehr Lehrkräfte kleinere
Klassen klar aber was ist mit Didaktik
und Lehrmaterial Luisa
hoben Lehrerin Anja elix will einem
hohen Anspruch gerecht werden sie will
jedes Kind in ihrer vierten Klasse
individuell fördern sicherstellen dass
alle gut rechnen lesen und schreiben
können wer fertig ist schnappt sich
vorne ein iPad die gehören in der
lerundschule in Stuttgart längst zum
Unterricht dazu die Privatschule ist
Teil der klettgruppe vielen bekannt für
ihre Schulbücher zweimal pro Woche üben
die viertkläler Mathe und Deutsch mit
einer lnapp wir müssen halt Aufgaben
machen und die sind halt auch oft
spielerisch manche schwieriger manche
leichter und da läuft dann halt auch
immer so eine Zeit ab dann weiß man was
man verbessern kann und was
man schonut
die Kinder motiviert die Lehrerin
profitiert von den Daten denn die
Testergebnisse kann sie einsehen weiß wo
ein Kind in welchem Bereich steht was es
noch nicht kann beim Lesen dann hat das
Kind 58 Punkte erreicht der grüne
Bereich da ist dann alles in Ordnung
hier im rechtsschreiben sieht man da ist
es bei der Stufe 2 und da müssen wir
dann noch nachsteuern die Strategie
dahinter heißt testen testen testen und
die Kinder mit ihrem Ergebnis nicht
allein lassen persönliche Kontakt ist
natürlich immer wichtig gerade um den
Kindern auch bei schwierigen Sachen zu
helfen Japan oder Singapur sind so sehr
erfolgreich sie belegen bei PISA die
vorderen Plätze Deutschland hingegen
viel zurück um aufzuholen müsse
Unterricht individueller werden fordert
verlagsunternehmer David Klett geht
immer darum zu testen und dann zu sagen
was ist die nächste richtige
Intervention damit das Kind besser
versteht dass es besser wird in der
Beherrschung dessen was es lernen soll
ein Anspruch der vielerorts an der
Realität scheitert Johannes knapp ist
Konrektor der Stuttgarter pragschule
manche Schüler hier können bei der
Einschulung lesen andere sprechen kein
Wort Deutsch Tablets und Tests allein
reichen da nicht was uns da als
Kollegium fehlt ist die richtige
Konsequenz draus nämlich nicht nur
Fördermaterialien nicht nur
Differenzierung Unterricht sondern an
mehr an Personal und ich glaube wenn wir
das hätten könnten wir viele Punkte
lösen damit digitale Medien im
Unterricht tatsächlich einen Unterschied
machen müssen Sie eine wissenschaftliche
Basis haben sagt Psychologin Ulrike
Gress sie müssen sich im Lehrplan
einfügen und von Lehrkräften gut
bedienbar sein das Heß eine große
Aufgabe vor der wir stehen in der
Bildungspraxis ist die Entwicklung
dieser Materialien von Lehrbüchern
kennen wir es es dauert Jahre bis man
ein gutes Lehrbuch entwickelt bis man
ein gutes digitales Medium entwickelt
dauert im Prinzip noch länger weil die
Möglichkeiten für Digitalität viel
größer sind schafft es Schule die
digitalen Möglichkeiten zu nutzen könne
es tatsächlich gelingen kann jedes Kind
das Üben was es noch nicht kann jedes
Kind individuell gefördert
werden individuelles und digitales
lernen ist das der Weg für eine bessere
Zukunft der Kinder die ja eh in einer
digitalen Realität aufwachsen Annika
Renker bei der klettgruppe ist zuständig
für Bildungsfragen und damit schönen
guten Abend nach Düsseldorf schönen
guten Abend Frau Hayali Frau Renker die
pisaergebnisse die waren ein Schock mit
Ansage neben Lehrermangel zu großen
Klassen zu viel Unterrichtsausfall liegt
es vielleicht auch am
Lehrmaterial also es gibt natürlich eine
große Vielzahl an Lehrmaterialien also
da gibt's wirklich alles vom Lehrwerk
logischerweise wie es die meisten Leute
kennen es gibt freie Materialien es gibt
handlungsorientierte Materialien
projektbücher also es gibt wirklich
alles was das Herz begehrt und natürlich
analog wie digital ähm aus meiner Sicht
sind diese Materialien vor allem Dingen
dafür da um Lehrkräfte zu unterstützen
und um Lehrkräfte zu entlasten und um
Unterricht zu gestalten also die
Kompetenz der Lehrkräfte zu ergänzen um
einen guten Unterricht zu machen und da
spielen sie eine wichtige Rolle nach wie
vor aus meiner Sicht dann schauen wir
mal auf das digitale 25% der
Viertklässler könn ich richtig lesen
jede dritte neunklässler neunklässlerin
kann ich richtig multiplizieren
Grundschulkinder die keine 20 Sekunden
konzentriert zuhören können jetzt gerade
der letzte Punkt ist da war das Tablet
Schuld es kommt immer drauf an wie ein
Tablet eingesetzt wird also natürlich
wissen wir dass Übernutzung von Medien
und der überdurchschnittliche Konsum von
Medien dazu führen kann dass Kinder sich
nicht gut konzentrieren können wenn man
aber digitale Medien mit einem guten
Konzept im Unterricht verankert und
nicht ausschließlich mit digitalen
Medien arbeitet dann sollte das nicht
dazu führen dass sich Kinder nicht
konzentrieren können sondern dann können
sie sehr gezielt mit digitalen Medien
sehr gut gefördert werden und vor allen
Dingen können Sie individuell gefördert
werden was in Zeiten von
Lehrkräftemangel eigentlich ohne
digitale Unterstützung kaum möglich ist
es ist aber wirklich wichtig dass man
nicht das eine gegen das andere
ausspielt sondern dass in der Schule
immer ein sowohl als auch gilt und nicht
ein entweder oder ja bei der reduzierten
Lernleistung muss man auch sagen der
digitalpack den gibt es seit 2019 der
ist angelaufen extrem langsam das
Bildungsniveau war aber schon lange
davor gesunken wie sieht denn für sie
ein sinnvoller Einsatz digital Medien in
Kita und in der Schule aus also aus
meiner Sicht kann man digitale Medien
sehr gut einsetzen um Lernstände
festzustellen von Kindern und um diese
Lernstände sehr schnell auszuwerten wenn
Sie jedes einzelne Kind auf Papier
testen und danach die Lehrkraft dieses
Papier korrigieren muss und auswerten
muss dann dauert das sehr lange das geht
mit digitalen Medien extrem schnell die
Kinder können die Tests digital machen
man stellt einen Lernstand fest und dann
kann danach direkt individuell gefördert
werden das ging auch digital das geht
auch mit mit Papier aber da ist ein
großes entlastungspotenzial in diesen
Zeiten gegeben dass die Lehrkräfte nicht
eigenständig alles auswerten müssen und
kann dieses individuelle fördern
eventuell dazu führen dass es erst
rechtverlierer gibt die die z.B dann den
das Gemeinschaftsgefühl flöten geht die
zu Hause keine Unterstützung haben
gerade was Tablets und ähnliches
anbelangt nein es geht jetzt ja nicht
darum die Kinder alle einzeln vorer
Tablet zu sitzen und dass die nicht mehr
zusammenarbeiten wie gesagt es ist immer
ein guter didaktischer Mix wichtig und
natürlich auch Gruppenarbeit und
Projektarbeit neben den individuellen
Zeiten und
wenn alle Kinder getestet werden und
alle Kinder dort gefördert werden wo sie
ihre Lücken haben dann profitiert jedes
Kind davon nicht nur die Schwachen auch
die starken und
dann kann jedes Kind vorankommen und
dann kann eine andere Lernzeit die
vielleicht in der Gruppe passiert auch
entspannter davon statten gehen nach dem
ersten pisaschock vor über 20 Jahren hat
sich kaum was an den Strukturen geändert
drumherum hat sich fast alles geändert
mal schauen was jetzt die Konsequenzen
sind Frau Rinker vielen Dank für Ihre
Zeit und fürs Gespräch ich danke Ihnen
Frau
Haali ja und wenn jedes Kind profitieren
soll braucht auch jedes Kind ein Tablet
das Gespräch haben wir kurz vor der
Sendung aufgezeichnet und wir blicken
jetzt auf das größte blutbart in der
Geschichte der heutigen Tschechischen
Republik kaisve damit beginnen deine
Nachrichten ja noch immer ist unklar
warum der Täter gestern das Feuer
eröffnete einen terroristischen
Hintergrund Schließen der Ermittler aber
aus inzwischen korrigierten sie die
Opferzahl von 15 auf 14 viele Menschen
tortout zeigten ihre Trauer der
24-Jährige Schütze hatte wohl zunächst
seinen Vater getötet später feuerte er
dann in der Prager Karlsuniversität um
sich offenbar tötete er sich dann selbst
bereits vor einer Woche hatte er
vermutlich einen Spaziergänger und
dessen zwei Monate alte Tochter
ermordet bes Sitzer die eine
klimafreundliche Heizung einbauen wollen
haben nun Klarheit darüber mit welcher
Förderung Sie rechnen können wer eine
alte Anlage ersetzt erhält 30% der
Kosten einkommensschwache Haushalte
können außerdem einen einkommensbonus
von 30% beantragen und wer früh umrüstet
kann auf zusätzliche 20% hoffen die
Gesamtförderung ist auf 70%
begrenzt anderthalb Jahre nach dem
Zugunglück von garmischpartenkirchen hat
die die Staatsanwaltschaft München
offenbar Anklage gen drei
Bahnmitarbeiter erhoben unter anderem
wegen fahrlässiger Tötung das berichten
mehrere Medien die Ermittler selbst
äußerten sich nicht im Juni 22 war ein
Regionalzug auf dem Weg nach München
entgleist fünf Menschen starben 78
wurden verletzt ursache waren
wahrscheinlich beschädigte
Betonschwellen wer zwischen Weihnachten
und Silvester zum Arzt muss könnte vor
verschlossenen Türen stehen denn viele
niedergelassene Ärzte wollen streiken
Gesundheitsminister Lauterbach
kritisierte die Ankündigung jetzt wo
jeder zehnte krank sei dürften die
ohnehin schon vollen Praxen nicht
schließen sagte er dem rbb vorgestern
hatte Lauterbach einen Krisengipfel
angekündigt Hauptthemen neue Honorare
und weniger
Bürokratie das Wetter in Deutschland
bleibt herausfordernd in vielen
Mittelgebirgen warn der Deutsche
Wetterdienst vor ergiebigem Dauerregen
er folgt auf Sturm soltn der vergangene
Nacht über Deutschland fgte mehrere
Menschen wurden verletzt vor allem durch
umstürzende Bäume eine Sturmflut setzte
den Hamburger Fischmarkt unter Wasser
weil auch der Bahnverkehr gestört war
hingen viele Reisende fest oder machten
sich erst gar nicht auf den Weg morgen
dürften die Züge entsprechend voll
sein in deutschen Haushalten lebten im
vergangenen Jahr rund
34,4 Millionen Haustiere
unterschiedlichster Arten und wer sich
für ein solches entscheidet sollte sich
vorab viele Fragen stellen habe ich Zeit
habe ich Platz habe ich Geld letzteres
klingt unsexy ist aber mit die
relevanteste Frage denn von Liebe und
Verantwortungsbewusstsein allein kann
kein Tier überleben doch was tun wenn
plötzlich alles teurer wird das Tier das
für viele ja zu einem Familienmitglied
geworden ist für manche Menschen ist es
sogar der einzige Begleiter einfach
abgeben das ist für viele ein Albtraum
einer der aufgrund der steigenden Preise
allerdings wahr werden könnte Marlin
ilau sie verteilen Futterspenden an
Bedürftige Tierbesitzer die Tiertafel im
niedersächsischen gifforn gibt es seit
einem halben Jahr schon jetzt ist der
andran groß es kommen immer mehr
bedürftige Ivonne well gehausen muss
genau schauen wen sie noch aufnimmt die
Preise für Futtermittel und Tierzubehör
sind um teilweise 30% gestiegen das
können halt viele sich einfach nicht
mehr leisten und wenn es uns nicht geben
würde sind sie halt wirklich
verpflichtet zu überlegen was machen wir
mit unserem Tier und mit unserer
Unterstützung können wir das Tier das zu
Hause sichern wie bei Ellen Götze sie
hat früher als Krankenschwester
gearbeitet die Rente ist mager und
reicht eigentlich nicht um noch Katze
Lilli zu versorgen doch das Tier abgeben
das ist keine Option für Sie wenn ich
die Tafel nicht hätte wäre es sehr sehr
sehr schwierig dann müsste ich bei mir
Abstrichen noch mehr machen ne sie spart
für den Tierarzt Katze Lilli braucht
eine Zahnbehandlung die kostet mehrere
hundert Euro für Götze nicht leistbar
für viele Tierbesitzer brechen
schwierige Zeiten an die neue
Gebührenordnung für Tierärzte stellt
Tierhalter vor finanzielle
Herausforderungen Narkosen und
Untersuchungen sind deutlich teurer
geworden doch Tiere zu halten das sollte
man sich auch leisten können sagt sie es
ist schon etwas was man sich vorher auf
jeden Fall bitte gut überlegen darf
bevor man sich ein Tier neu ins Haus
holt auch wenn ein Tier älter wird
und Vorsorgeuntersuchung oder
weiterführende Therapie begleitende
Untersuchungen notwendig sind oder auch
Medikamente das ist eben nicht umsonst
und man muss es halt wissen wie kann ich
das in meinen finanziellen Haushalt
einbauen ein Hund kann 10 bis 15 Jahre
alt werden die Kosten die er erzeugt
können hoch sein mehrere tausend Euro
Tiermedizin ist eine private Leistung
wer hierhin kommt kann sich keine
Tierarztkosten mehr leisten das
tierarztmobil der ul steinstiftung
bietet kostenlose Behandlungen an
ursprünglich vor Obdachlose Tierhalter
doch jetzt kommen Rentner
Hilfsbedürftige und ukrainische
Flüchtlinge mit ihren Vierbeinern vielen
ist das Tier und die Gesundheit des Tier
ist wichtiger als ihr eigenes die kaufen
auch am Monatsanfang oft Tierfutter oder
erstmal Sachen für Ihren Hund und sind
völlig verzweifelt dann auch wenn der
Hund krank ist und rufen an und weinen
und sagen oh ich kann es mir nicht
leisten und für dir ist es schon sehr
wichtig dass Sie hier eine Anlaufstelle
haben das tierarztmobil ist hier für
viele die letzte Station für
verzweifelte Halter die nicht ihren
vierbeine abgeben wollen durch Hund
kommt man in soziale
Kontakte ja man hat eine Aufgabe eine
Pflicht muss raus muss früh aufstehen ja
das ist nicht bloß ein Prestigeobjekt
wie viele denken ja Tiere geben Menschen
halt besonders
[Musik]
die der Hund blieb mir im Sturme treu
der Mensch nicht mal im Winde wir machen
weiter mit Preisen die allerdings
gesunken sind ke Ärger von
immobilienverkäufern denn die Preise für
Häuser und Wohnungen sind im dritten
Quartal so stark gefallen wie seit über
20 Jahren nicht mehr platzt da gerade
eine Blase Valerie Haller in Frankfurt
ja ob es sich überhaupt um eine
Immobilienblase gehandelt hat ist unter
Ökonomen umstritten wäre sie jetzt
geplatzt ist sie wenigstens schwer
vergleichbar mit anderen Blasen weder
gab es breitflächig Ausfälle bei
Baukrediten noch massenweise baau Ruinen
wie damals nach der Finanzkrise in
Spanien die Preise für Immobilien fallen
zwar aktuell stark im Vergleich zum
Vorjahr verbilligten sich Wohnimmobilien
im dritten Quartal im Schnitt um
10,2%. dabei erfasst der Preisrutsch nah
zuu alle Regionen auf dem Land oder in
Metropolen über einen Zeitraum von 5
Jahren Betracht aber war der
Preisverfall weit weniger dramatisch
also manche sprechen von einer
geplatzten Blase andere nicht wichtiger
ist vielleicht der Blick nach vorne ja
wohin werden sich die Immobilienpreise
denn künftig entwickelt was erwartet man
da ja die Preise dürften auch im
kommenden Jahr weiter fallen wenn auch
nicht ganz so stark für stabilere Preise
spricht dass nach wie vor zu wenig
gebaut wird der Bedarf weiter groß ist
der Weg zum Eigenheim bleibt also
vermutlich steinig zum einen weil die
Zinsen vorerst hoch bleiben dürften und
zum anderen sind Immobilien immer noch
deutlich teurer als vor dem Boom danke
Valerie an die
Börse der frühere usbotschafter in
Deutschland john cornblum ist gestorben
er galt als einer der renommiertesten
Transatlantik Experten 1987 soll er die
Idee für Ronald ragons berühmten Satz Mr
gorbachchov tear down this wall gehabt
haben 10 Jahre später wurde er im
wiederereinigten Deutschland Botschafter
bis zuletzt meldete er sich als scharfer
politischer Beobachter zu Wort er wurde
80 Jahre
alt und im Alter von 76 Jahren ist
Ingrid Steger gestorben als
Schauspielerin brachte sie Millionen
Menschen zum Lachen ihre eigene
Geschichte war voller Tragik um
Konventionen scherte sie sich wenig in
beiden Welten
Ulknudel und umschwärmtes Sexsymbol
Ingrid Steger in den
70ern ihre Lebensgeschichte ein großes
auf und ab sie wächst im vom Zweiten
Weltkrieg zerbomten Berlin auf zu Hause
gibt es kein Geld und keine Liebe
stattdessen Misshandlungen sie ist
schüchtern und unsicher trotzdem jobt
sie als Fotomodel dann wird sie fürs
Fernsehen entdeckt sexy und unschuldig
zugleich die Mischung kommt
anim bim ist 1973 ihr großer Durchbruch
die freche Fernsehshow wirkult Ingrid
Steger spielt Gabi eine Art
horrorpipiangstrumpf wie W heute mit
Revue Fragen Harald Junke und Ingrid
Steger in den 80ern und präsentieren
Sketsche prominente Gäste und
Tanzeinlagen viele Männer liegen ihr zu
Füßen die große Liebe findet sie nicht
zwei Ehen und zahlreiche Beziehungen
scheitern glücklich ist sie eine Zeit
lang mit Regisseur Dieter Wedel der sie
auch für die Reihe der große Bellheim
engagiert die Fernsehauftritte werden
seltener sie spielt Theater geht unter
anderem mit der alten Klimbim Familie
auf Tour private und finanzielle
Tiefschläge bringen sie aus dem 2010 ist
die
Pleite sie rappelt sich auf ausgerechnet
eine Rolle in einer Harz 4 Komödie hilft
ihr wieder auf die Beine inzwischen ist
sie dankbar für die schwere Zeit
schreibt sie 2013 in ihrer
Autobiografie in den letzten Jahren war
es ruhiger um Ingrid Steger geworden sie
hatte sich aus der Öffentlichkeit
zurückgezogen wenn man selber Fan ist
ist es schwierig einigermaßen nüchtern
bis neutral ein Thema anzumoderieren
aber wer hat nicht irgendeinen
Lieblingsfilm oder eine Lieblingsfigur
aus der Welt der Walt Disney Company
meine ist Donald Duck welche ist ihre
Aladdin Arielle Alis im Wunderland Simba
aus der König der Löwen Mulan mugli
Balou Peter Pan pinokchio Rapunzel tzan
wiinu und die Liste geht ja endlos
weiter disney hat Figuren schaffen und
Filme gchaffen die ihresgleichen suchen
klar das Erfolgsrezept oftmals süße
Tiere mit menschlichen Eigenschaften die
irgendeinen bösen bezwingen müssen ja
das mag veraltet sein und doch zieht es
immer wieder und immer noch auch nach
100 Jahren Claudia
Batz es begann mit einem Mann der eine
Maus zeichnete ein amerikanischer Held
war geboren es macht Spaß das Unmögliche
zu tun war der Grundsatz des
Zeichentrick Pioniers Walt Disney und
mit Micky Maus kam der große
Erfolg ein vorlauter Charakter in den
Jahren der Wirtschaftskrise erfüllte er
die Sehnsucht nach einem Stehaufmännchen
mit steamoat Willy begann der Aufstieg
zu einem der größten
Unterhaltungskonzerne der
Welt willkommen an diesem Ort des Glücks
Disneyland ist euer
Land für den Bau des ersten Disneyland
Parks verkaufte Wal sein eigenes Haus um
der Pleite zu
entgehen ich hatte das Gefühl man müsste
einen Ort schaffen an dem Eltern und
Kinder gemeinsam Spaß haben
können und wieder ging seine Vision auf
bis heute lassen die Vergnügungsparks
die Kassen
klingeln Disney das war war immer schon
ganz großes
Gefühl die Sehnsucht nach kitschiger
Wohlfühlwärme es zeigt dass Amerika der
Helden ein Amerika das in seliger
Selbstzufriedenheit
schwellkte doch seit dem riesenerfolk
Schneewittchen von
1937 hat sich die Welt verändert und
Disney
[Musik]
auch heute hat sich der Konzern der
Diversität verschrieben Arielle die
Meerjungfrau ist nicht nur eine selbst
bewusste Heldin sondern sie ist jetzt
schwarz und ging es früher noch um
Traumprinzen werden jetzt weibliche
befreiungshymnen geschmettert sogar im
Weißen
[Musik]
Haus Disney unterstützt auch die lgbtq
Community und wird dafür von ganz rechts
angefeindet woke ruft auch Ron de Santis
der Gouverneur von Florida und sagt
Disney den Kampf an doch einen
Kulturkampf für Disney
keineswegs in Wirklichkeit geht es nicht
um wokeness sondern um Kapitalismus sie
versuchen einfach Ihren Markt so weit
wie möglich
auszudehnen und so ist Disney einer der
bekanntesten Markennamen der Welt
produzierte einige der erfolgreichsten
Filme aller Zeiten und wurde belohnt mit
140 Oscars folgt dem Zeitgeist und
bleibt sich doch seit 100 Jahren treu
die Welt ist eingeteilt in Gut und Böse
und am Ende füllt sich immer unsere eine
große Sehnsucht dass die Gerechtigkeit
siegt und immer Happy End ist eigentlich
auch langweilig bis mal keines kommt und
dann regt man sich auf aber ist ein gut
Stichworte noch wir machen jetzt Schluss
empfehlen Ihnen noch das heute journal
Update um vi mit Hanna Zimmermann das
war's von uns und vom gesamten Team
machen sie es gut wo auch immer Sie
sind
[Musik]
guten Abend dass an Weihnachten in
Deutschland selten Schnee liegt ist
bekannt aber warum für weiße Weihnachten
müssen genug Kälte und genug
Feuchtigkeit vorhanden sein das Problem
die kältehochs über Russland bringen aus
Nordosten zwar eisige aber knochentr
trockene Luft feuchter ist die
wolkenreiche Luft durch ein Atlantik
tief aus Westen sie kommt übers Wasser
ist aber oft zu mild und es gibt Regen
statt Schnee erst wenn beides zusammenkt
fällt ordentlich
Neuschnee dieses Jahr ist von einem
Kältehoch aber nichts zu sehen da liegt
das abziehende Sturmtief soltern aber an
dieser Luftmassengrenze bleibt es weiter
turbulent und so sind auch heute Abend
und in der Nacht wieder schwere
sturmböhen möglich an der See auf den
Bergen und im Alpenvorland und es regnet
weiter kräftig vor allem im Stau der
Mittelgebirge da ist über das Wochenende
immer häufiger Hochwasser möglich es
schneit sich gleichzeitig richtig ein im
Erzgebirge und in den Alpen trocken
bleibt es nur im Nordosten heute Nacht
hier am kühlsten bis -1° am Rhein bleibt
es bei 8° und dieser
luftmassenunterschied ist auch morgen zu
erkennen im Nordosten 3 bis 6° im Westen
und im Süden 5 bis 11° hier ist die
Sturmgefahr morgen auch am größten mit
schweren sturmböhen in Berglagen und im
Alpen Vorland im Nordosten ist es morgen
am freundlichsten wie heute von
Südwesten lässt der Regen im
Tagesverlauf langsam nach den
kräftigsten Regen gibt es im Bereich der
Luftmassengrenze von der Nordsee bis zum
Erzgebirge hier eben anfangs noch
kräftiger Schneefall zum Abend hin
steigt die Schneefallgrenze dann schnell
an denn für die Feiertage gilt es ist
sehr mild an Heilig Abend gibt es aber
noch viel Regen und Sturm am ersten und
am zweiten Weihnachtsfeiertag gibt es
weniger Wind und weniger Regen und dann
schaut ab und an auch die Sonne raus
tschüss